ashley thank you well because of the
wind as you mentioned the county issuing
that dust advisory for saturday
and sunday they expect the unhealthy air
quality could affect you if you have
breathing sensitivity so here are some
reminders you don't want to exert
yourself if you're sensitive to the dust
if you're out doing heavy exercise for
example you're going to breathe heavier
and you're likely to inhale more of
those small dust particles you want to
keep your windows and your doors closed
you don't want that dust blowing inside
it's also not a lot of fun to clean up
run your air conditioner in both your
home and your car even if you love the
heat that's going to help filter out all
that bad stuff that we don't want to be
breathing in and
speaking of that consider changing your
indoor air filters because they're
likely dirty if you haven't done that
yet this season there's also a number
that you can call to report excessive
amounts of dust blowing around in your
area we got a lot of stuff under
construction here also might live next
to a vacant lot that number here easy to
remember because it ends in dust it is
385
dust